[Music]
I've never been with a gang star but day
squares not squares but I like just a
regular guy good
boys and girls
yeah that's they you
know I don't know exactly what that cold
open was either but I'm Dave Ruben this
is the Ruben report we are live from
Miami in the Free State of Florida as
always it is November 14th 2023 we're
live streaming on Rumble YouTube and
locals postgame show at Ruben report.
locals.com immediately after the program
if you want want to get in and question
me comment share your thoughts etc etc
uh and by the way our second show which
we launched last week people of the
internet which normally is live every uh
Monday through Thursday at 1 p.m.
Eastern uh today we have our reasons I
can't always explain everything well I
guess I could explain why I'm on Russell
Brand's show right after this so we have
to delay it just a little bit uh till 2
p.m. Eastern and if you want to catch me
with Russell Brand uh that will be on
his channel on Rumble uh I think
immediately after basically noon Eastern
uh the theme today and we have a
jam-packed program I am very proud of
today's rundown I think you're going to
dig it uh the theme today is when does
the left go too far this is a question
that Jordan Peterson has been asking
democrats for years and years when we
were on tour back in 2018 he was meeting
with Democrats in Congress to talk about
this to talk about what we all what we
we now all call woke and all of this
craziness like what are the things that
you good liberals and Democrats are
going to do when the crazy people in
your party go completely bananas and he
could not get an answer on this he
questioned Bill Maher about it the other
night and that's going to kind of set us
up uh for today's show because it's not
just now that we have lefties defending
the most horrific atrocities imaginable
uh but they are also defending people
who would gladly have our borders be
overrun they are defending people who
would gladly have our cities be overrun
not only via the illegals who are coming
over the Border but with drugs and
everything else and of course if you
stand up and say anything against them
you are called Hitler and or a Nazi so
the question is what the independence
moderates and good liberals have to do I
think you know my answer we'll get to
that in just a second so let's kick it
off uh with another clip we showed you
one or two yesterday but there's a
different one of Jordan Peterson on Real
Time with Bill Maher last last night
posing that very question when does the
left go too far but what happens is that
they are then saying that being
oppressed is I know if the Holocaust
well this but this is the this is the
main issue I mean part of the reason
that you see all this foolishness on
University campuses too is because
people have bought this idiot metam
Marxism which is that the way to look at
every social relationship that people
ever have is through the lens of power
and that that is we can put that
squarely at the feet of the universities
as far as concerned is you know marriage
is a patriarchal institution and
business is nothing but oppression and
you have to view every single situation
that emerged historically as oppressor
versus oppressed and then once you get
that which you can get in about 2
minutes if you see it in the course that
teaches that sort of thing you have a
lens to moralize about the whole world
through and then you see the situation
is that the leftists have already
decided the Palestinians are the victims
and as you pointed out if you're a
victim then you're morally righteous and
even more conveniently if you stand for
the victim then you're morally righteous
regardless of what you do with your own
life and that's pretty much what
University students are taught from the
time they enter the university classroom
and that's how they you know Orient
themselves morally and that's at the
hands of the radical left to Bill and
one of the things the Democrats also
have to pay the price for I would say is
their absolute refusal to draw a line
between the modern Democrats and the
extremists they're completely incapable
of doing that like I've talked to 40
senators Congressman in The Last 5 Years
I asked them all the same question
including RFK he wouldn't answer either
when does the left go too far well we
certainly bloody well saw it in the last
month didn't we because they got the
oppressor oppressor narrative uh little
mucked up we might say and we're going
to the consequences of that are going to
unfold pretty brutally over the next few
months man if I do nothing else in my
career the fact that I had anything even
like the slightest pin drop of a thing
to do with getting people to know that
guy that would be more than enough that
they could put on my Epitaph I just want
to mention that you know he mentioned
RFK at the end and RFK who of course
when Jordan interviewed him and
mentioned that when does the left go too
far and RFK didn't have an answer RFK
was still a Democrat he subsequently has
left the Democrat Party uh we didn't
have time to pull it right before the
show maybe we'll do a short about it or
we can get it in tomorrow's show but
when I interviewed RFK a couple weeks
ago live in LA I mentioned to him that
the day he announced that I said I don't
know that he's going to be a republican
by the end of this thing but he
certainly will not be a Democrat because
he has finally realized that the left
has gone too far so Jordan's it's so
great how Jordan just levels everything
up there right like he's making the the
realtime show better than it actually is
he's making Bill like go deeper into
these issues because once you decide
these people are the oppressors and
these people people are the oppressed
there is nothing that the oppressed can
not do to the oppressors so it doesn't
matter how many babies they burn how
many Holocaust Survivors they shoot in
the head or how many grandmothers they
rape or what all the stuff it does not
matter right that actually as many
people said after October 7th well what
did you think decolonization meant so
there is no evil that goes too far so
they tried blowing up buses for many
years and suicide bombing for many years
and blowing up planes and stabbing
people and all of those things and the
world kind of didn't care because of
this nonsensical and it's it's
completely fabricated and nonsensical
and it's actually downright evil this
notion that you it's either oppressed
it's it's either oppressed or oppressor
and that's how you figure out good guys
and bad guys one side is always culpable
of everything the other side is never
culpable of anything and then as Jordan
points out the people who have nothing
to do with it but the people who are
Marching and the gender queer dingbats
and the gay for Palestine everything
they are then getting this faux uh
morality right they're getting faux
worth by showing how much they are for
the oppressed of course it will only be
a short line until the oppressed start
beheading them and then I guess we'll
have to cover that on the show too
because you know we do what we can
anyway if you want a perfect example of
when the left goes too far this this
almost I like the chef's kiss this is
one of them so Jeremy Corbin he was the
leader of the labor party in for many
years in the UK uh he fought very hard
against brexit right he's a globalist
he's a socialist he has been a Hamas and
a Hezbollah apologist for years rabid
hatred of Israel Pi's Morgan and Piers
I'm very conflicted about Piers I've
done his show a couple times he kind of
takes every position on everything but
he does give a voice to some people who
should have a voice in mainstream so
okay in any event and and also as an
interviewer it's a lot of what you're
about to see watch this this is
absolutely incredible last night he
asked Jeremy Corman former head of the
labor party so in essence he's there
Bernie
Sanders 15 times whether he thinks that
Hamas is a terrorist group watch this
can we have a discussion can you call
them a terror group can we have a disc
you call them a terror group is it
possible to have a rational discussion
are you prepar to call H terror group is
it possible to have a rational you is it
possible come on answer that question
you answer it no it's my show you answer
my question are you are the are herass a
terror group listen can I are they a
terror group PE can I speak answer the
question can I speak are they a terror
group PE if you let me speak are they a
terror group if you let me speak I'll
say something go on then a ceasefire
means both sides you said that are they
a terror group listen I said that
because are they ter grp part of the
process are they a terror group
will can we go why can't you say it
Piers can we go through what ought to be
happening just answer my question why do
you
think in the world are calling for a
ceas a terror group come on answer that
me your show you've got so many opinions
why should I answer yours when you
answer mine why do you give out your
opinions all day and every day you don't
like
it areass a terror group yes or no you
won't let you want like it with
something back on you what I've said is
I've asked you two questions should a
mass stay in power and they terror group
you're refusing to answer either of them
that is very telling and you wonder and
you wonder why people think you had a
problem with Jewish people all is all
right I sort of feel like I have to
apologize for showing you that clip
because in some ways that right there
like that version of television and the
way that debate has devolved is sort of
exactly why I started this show and try
to interview people the way I do and
communicate the way I do about some of
these important issues uh but yes 15
times here's Morgan asked him to just
say that Hamas is a terrorist group now
keep in mind this is the same question
that was posed to AOC in the halls of
Congress we showed you that and Rashid T
and ilhan Omar and they refuse to say it
so they don't think that a group that
breaks into someone's borders and
randomly with maximal violence and and
just like un
Unthinkable
evil does all of the stuff puts babies
into ovens yes they did that and beheads
women and rapes people and goes to a
party and shoots as many people as
possible and throws grenades into
shelters to to MIM people I saw another
video I put it up this morning of of
some of that from October 7th I mean
it's just unimaginable but he just can't
say they are a terrorist group because
he is a Hamas supporter and he has been
for a long time so let me relate that to
the top of the show Jordan Peterson's
question to Bill Maher and to RFK and to
to Really everybody when does the left
go too far and if no one on the left can
ever say boy we've gone a little too far
this time when we have calls for
genocide on the street in New York City
and people praising Hitler on the
streets of Dearborn Michigan and all
those things if no good liberal and and
it's not to say no none because there
are like little bites of people but at
but at sort of a national level any real
leader is afraid to say you know
enough's enough uh then they have a real
problem on their hands now I want to
show you a clip and and I have to say
before I show this on a personal note uh
I was part of the young turky for a
couple years in 2013 and 14 they're a
far-left progressive YouTube channel I
guess and when I was there I was a
progressive I I think I'd like to think
that I was not completely insane Lefty
and on certain issues I definitely
wasn't there were a couple times that uh
flareups happened between Hamas and
Israel and I would defend Israel against
five people including two who were my
boss and a whole bunch more and they
were always screaming about everything
and everything else anyway I'm going to
show you a clip now of Jank yuger he is
the the head of The Young Turks in all
the years since I left The Young Turks
so I left in 2014 I think so it's almost
9 years ago I don't know that I've ever
played one clip of him have I ever
played one single clip of him on this
show I don't think so they have done
hundreds of videos lying about me and
saying all sorts of awful things and
selectively editing everything else uh
Phoenix brought this video to my
attention last night because it was
making the rounds and I think it's worth
showing uh because there is a certain
set of people when you talk about the
left going too far they have no idea
about history most of their whole
worldview is caught up in what Jordan
talked about oppressed vers oppressor so
you can excuse everything you can excuse
racism and then of course you can call
everyone else a racist so again on Piers
Morgan's show but this is from two days
ago I believe uh Rabbi Shmi Bak he's a
he's a rabbi who goes on in television
and and defends Jews and Israel I
suppose uh he gave a real lesson to Jank
yuger about the history of the Middle
East Jen was screaming and screaming and
screaming we're going to start with then
uh the rabbi explaining a little bit of
history and just watch Jen's reaction
I've spent I've spent my life debating
people whenever someone whenever someone
starts using personal names and
screaming like a lunatic they're losing
the debate let me Remain the one made
Palestinians the Palestinians the
Palestinians the the Palestinians were
offered a state in 1936 in the appeal
commission they rejected it they were
offered a state in 1947 the UN partition
plan they rejected it they were offered
to state in 1967 after Israel conquered
Judean Samar and the West Bank they
rejected it they were offered to state
in 2000 yasar Barack they rejected it
they were offered a state with aod om
2008 they rejected it they have Israel
unilaterally withdrew from Gaza in 2005
and they did not create a state in fact
where were you chank when you say that
you care about Palestinian children when
Hamas stole the highest rate of per
capita International foreign aid larger
than the Marshall Plan from pales Indian
children did not build schools for them
did not build hospitals took all the
money to buy bombs and to build a
network of tunnels which is larger than
the than the New York Subway system
where were you then why did you only
come up now in fact when Bashar al-assad
killed
600,000 children Arab children when he
gassed them with mustard gas my
organization took out full page New York
Times ads to protect them from sarin gas
where are you then you don't care about
Arab children you are a Jew hater Define
to someone who only wants to lie and say
that the Jews are genoci and don't try
to cancel me and say that I shouldn't be
on say you know I'm a little conflicted
not not just because For the First Time
In all the years I showed a video of him
but you know in some ways I I owe Jank a
certain amount of credit because if it
wasn't for seeeing his endless screaming
and lack of knowledge and historical
knowledge and actually his true bigotry
and all of those things I don't know
that I ever would have really woken up
to what the left was so so I don't
regret working there as embarrassing as
it is I suppose in some level in
retrospect that I had anything to do
with those people by the way the name
The Young Turks which is the name of the
network those were the groups of people
in Turkey who committed the Armenian
Genocide commit killed over a million
Armenians this is pre-World War I I
think it was what was it around 1910 if
I'm not mistaken and Hitler got the idea
of the Holocaust from The Young Turks
who were committing a genocide against
the Armenians cuz the world didn't care
about that so then Hitler was like oh I
guess I could probably pull this off
because the world won't care about that
so Jen literally named his organization
after uh an organization that was for a
genocide that committed a genocide which
if I'm not mistaken he still denies and
then of course he calls the rabbi a
racist and a bigot and the rest of it uh
but everything and I and I would welcome
you to fact check it everything that the
rabbi said there was true that the 1936
peel commission by the way you could
watch my interview with RFK he goes into
all the history too 19 47 partition plan
67 after that War uh 2000 2008 there
were so many times that the Palestinians
could have had a state it would have
been the first time they had a state
because there's never been a Palestinian
State the only people to ever offer the
Palestinians estate are the Israelis
these are the facts and that's why they
can be laid out calmly and cleanly
without screaming and without calling
everyone a racist but in some ways you
can't blame the people who are really
confused right because let's go back to
the top for a second the Democrats don't
know when to say enough is enough then
you get a series of people like Jeremy
Corbin who get elected based on lies and
bigotry using their oppressed depressor
thing and they get put into power and
they do all of the wrong things then you
have an a um uh an educational class
let's say that teaches people all of the
wrong things and then of course you have
a media class that lies and obfuscates
about absolutely everything so excuse me
so on MSNBC The televised mental
institution known as MSNBC uh here is
Andrea Mitchell and she is trying to
explain because she's sitting in New
York City in the Comforts of New York
City and she is a millionaire and they
have tons of security at that building
she's here she is trying to explain that
Israel is being a little heavy-handed in
what they're doing even though they know
and they everyone knows it and watch
she's she's a hopology and also
pathetically she's a Jew which is which
is just absolutely embarrassing but here
she is trying to explain that Israel is
being a bit harsh when it comes to
bombing certain things because uh people
might get killed and even though Hamas
knows exactly what they're doing Andrea
again millionaire uh New York City lot
of security but she she's better than
those people trying to uh make sure that
their children don't get raped John
Kirby thanks for being with us it's a
tough day let me start with the
hospitals even if Israel's claim that
Hamas command and control is under alifa
as well as under other hospitals other
Hamas units even if that were to Pro
true and my understanding is that the US
has not independently confirmed that
Intel does that justify striking a
hospital questions have been raised by
um General Brown CQ Brown and others
that even getting a couple of terrorists
or a terrorist cell doesn't
justify targeting a hospital Andre let
me just throw this one out to you you
you are a
horrible horrible human being You'
you've been a horrible broadcaster for
the 30 some odd years that you've been
on television you've been wrong about
almost everything you take the wrong
side on everything you apologize for
Hamas they would kill you you stupid Jew
they would gladly behead you Andrea
Mitchell and you think that if you offer
them a little Penance that somehow they
will be like oh you know Andrea Mitchell
she kind of defended us over the
hospital hpal where we had our
Communications underneath and we were
launching Rockets from guys could we
give Andrea Mitchell an extra 5 minutes
maybe you know before we behead her yeah
we were going to behead her now could we
just rape her for another five minutes
before we behead her that's the way this
thing ends you awful human being and and
and everyone in that building of MSNBC
you are all awful propagandists and
liars and don't worry we've got more
clips from MSNBC by the way when she
says that there's no independent
everyone knows everyone knows that the
shifa hospital in Gaza underneath that
is where Hamas is running operations
from everybody knows it everybody knows
it she's just a Hamas apologist and a
liar you are an embarrassment Andrea
Mitchell you know I saw her at the
airport once picking up a bag and I
should have said
something anyway uh let's before we do
more with MSNBC let's shift ship shift
over to another propaganda Network this
one CNN uh they brought on a doctor her
name is Barbara zind and uh here she is
explaining that Israel isn't giving
Hamas enough fuel and stuff uh because
there's a hospital and even though
they've kidnapped 200 Israelis and they
have a three-year-old American baby and
they murdered all those people and the
beheadings and all of the stuff why
can't they just give them more fuel for
their Hospital those freaking Jews who
won't feed and give fuel to the people
trying to kill them Jews one of
the big conversations has been allowing
fuel uh from Israel into Gaza that was a
non-starter but now the Israeli
government has for example IDF says it
placed 300 lers of fuel outside of the
alifa hospital there's this video I'll
show everyone this was provided to CNN
by them we can't independently verify
the video but the hospital's director
said the staff was too afraid to go
outside and even get that fuel that's
the IDF bringing the fuel because of the
strikes nearby and and he also noted and
I'd like your take on this doctor that
that amount of fuel 300 lers would only
run Hospital generators for about 30
minutes
um I know that they have huge generators
because they're used to power outages
and you know before the war in Gaza
you'd have four hours on four hours off
so in that four hours off all the
hospitals had their generators going I'm
not sure of the capacity or how much
fuel it uses but I'm sure that they
would use a lot I mean at this point
even the rooms are not are not
functional um all the because of the
bombing the glass is broken and all the
patients are in corridors which doesn't
have an oxygen supply and doesn't have
all the all that you need to care for a
patient that would explain these images
to us why we see so many of those
hospital beds in the hallways and not in
in in the rooms I mean these this is not
third world medicine they have upto-date
intensive care units that are now
destroyed nonfunctional and it's yeah
it's it's difficult to difficult to
hear Dr Barbara Zen thank you as always
you've really as I said last time helped
guide us through evil evil you know when
they tell you that the Jews control the
media I'm starting to think it's not
true because the entire mainstream media
is rabidly against Israel what other
Army in the in the world in the history
of the world a month after they have
killed 1500 year people and all of the
stuff that I have repeated repeatedly at
this point on this show and and I will
continue to repeat who what other army
in the world would be like oh and here
we're going to put our troops In Harm's
Way right there could be snipers out
there there could be uh eids IEDs on the
on the ground there we're going to put
our troops in the middle of the night to
put some gas there so that you can keep
some of these generators running no
other Army would do that every other
Army on Earth including the army of the
United States would have blown apart
that hospital and killed everybody how
remember when we were having a problem
with Isis what was it about seven years
ago and we just blew apart all of Syria
and all the Middle East how many how
many civilian casualties were there was
that proportionate I mean they did kill
one or two Americans it this this entire
thing is an absolute farce and until we
completely call it what it is we are
going to keep making the same mistakes
but Andrea Mitchell should be ashamed
whoever that CNN person is it doesn't
even matter she should be ashamed does
that doctor care about the 200 hostages
the three-year-old American baby what
why is it the responsibility of the
Israelis who had no literally not one
citizen living in Gaza on October 6th
had not one military installation in
Gaza it was they could have done
whatever they wanted with it right they
turned it into a a Haven for mass murder
not only of Israelis but of Gins simple
true that's it but the mainstream media
will not tell you who the terrorists are
and then what they do is if you push
back against the actual terrorists and
the actual terrorist
sympathizers yes they call you the Nazi
and they call you Hitler so one of the
thing that's happen things that's
happening right now is that Trump is
sort of back into their ecosystem their
sense is that Trump is going to win this
primary there's polls showing that he's
going to beat Joe Biden so we got to
ramp up the Hitler stuff so remember the
Democrat base and the progressives and
the Hamas caucus and all these people
they're out there on the streets calling
for genocide gas the Jews River to the
Sea all that stuff that's not hitlery
and nazil likee right that's that's you
know they're ripping down American flags
putting up Palestinian Flags desecrating
monuments of
uh of Jefferson and and many others
those are somehow the good guys but if
you talk about them then you're the
Hitler guys so this one's just
spectacular so Brian stelter we haven't
done a video of him in a while Mr Potato
Head himself who got fired from CNN
because nobody was watching his show it
was the brunt of every joke on the
internet uh he was sharing
misinformation whether it was Donald
Trump veryify people on both sides
Russia collusion BR havan a serial
rapist you know all the stuff he gets
fired from CNN he now writes a book
about misinformation and everything else
and then they put him back on CNN to
promote it do do we have a like a boxing
glove or something that I can just punch
myself in the face with rather than
watching this here go and I'm glad you
just played that clip of him describing
his opponents as Vermin that's a
horrifying clip that's a fascist clip
you know often times fascism is
perceived as a expansionist warlike you
know idea from the 1930s from Hitler's
Germany but Trump is this kind of
isolationist F fascist in terms of his
rhetoric over the weekend he goes to
give a Veterans Day speech and then
talks about rooting out Vermin from the
left that is shocking and it's not the
kind of thing we can ever get numb to
there's so much there first off Brian
steler again he got fired from CNN for
lying and thus over time more and more
people started making fun of his lies
and exposing his lies he got fired from
CNN what does he do he becomes a
professor at Harvard in media training
right because of course if you're going
to lie on mainstream media then you
you're a lefty you fail up you go to
Harvard and where would it be if you
were just like a lefty complete vapid
dishonest of course you would go
to Harvard of all places right he then
writes a book called network of lies and
then promotes that on
CNN irony is dead it is dead completely
dead bury it six feet under that's it
people he then calls Don Trump so of
course he's calling Donald Trump a
racist and he's he's a Hitler and Nazi
an isolationist fascist that's a new one
because we usually think of fascists
fascists want their government to take
over the world Hitler was a fascist and
he wanted Germany to invade all these
other countries in France and Britain
and Belgium and Holland and but Trump he
only cares about his little country so
he's a fascist
to I need to say ashanda is that what
it's called I should start taking it I
think it would help but let's Okay
that's one thing so I'm just going to
show you here so this is what they're
doing Trump's Hitler they did it for
years but they're bringing it back and
they're doing it as at the exact time
that there are people on the streets
calling for exactly what Hitler wanted
and they refuse to say anything about
those people so now let's go back to the
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC uh here is Nicole Wallace and uh
yes it is that Trump has always admired
Adolf Hitler I mean let's deal with
Hitler okay okay um Trump's affinity for
Hitler was always covered under an
umbrella of his stupidity right people
like General Kelly were like oh you must
not get it you must not mean Hitler's
Army right I mean he would talk about
the Brilliance of Hitler's generals
corre Kelly yes correct and and you've
got some reporting about about Merkel I
want you to explain that I'm going read
that but but but but tell me how Trump
sees Hitler well Trump clearly has this
infatuation with strong leaders he think
that's good they must be brilliant they
must be smart uh this is why he actually
was praising Hezbollah recently for
being smart uh but he talks about really
smart is what he said his his praise for
Kim Jong-un for for Putin uh for Victor
Orban uh of Hungary um you know the
the I I will get to to to to the Hitler
uh this amazing interaction that that he
had with um that he he recounted that he
had with uh with Angela Merkel I mean he
wants to be seen as a big strong leader
he wants to emulate these people I'm not
I'm not saying that Donald Trump is a
Nazi I don't I'm not but but there is
this infatuation that he has and he
Echoes his language I mean that's when
you were talking you know when he talks
about rooting out the Vermin even the
phrase uh the enemy of the people uh
which he used to describe the Press is
something that is drawn from Nazi
Germany it's also drawn from Stalin this
is a dictator's phrase and it's one that
he eagerly embraced does he know all the
history of it I don't know but the
parallel is clear I'm not going to call
him a Nazi but I'm going to spend my
entire time promoting my book on your TV
channel calling him a Nazi and by the
way the corporate press is the enemy of
the people and that doesn't make me a
Nazi or an authoritarian you people lie
about everything and it is direct
consequence it is a direct consequence
that your lies have led us to the place
that we are now at you know an
interesting little sidebar on this
Jonathan Carl guy so when I wrote don't
burn this book my first book uh that I
sold about 30,000 copies I think in the
first week which should have been number
two I think on the New York Times
bestseller list they put me at number 11
because they they just lie about their
whole thing and they put him his book
sold about 4,000 copies and sales are
known so you you don't have you know
you're not just pulling him out of thin
air they put him at number four he is
just part of the machine and he's now
making the rounds I'm not calling him
Hitler but let's talk about
Hitler so here's more of him on another
Show on MSNBC here he is with Jen Saki
and Jen saki remember she is not a
journalist she is a Democrat activist
who worked at the Biden Administration
she was a horrible press secretary so
then she gets a six-figure deal working
for MSNBC pretending she's doing news
and here he is again for a guy that
doesn't like to call Trump Hitler he
seems to be on a lot of TV shows calling
Trump Hitler it reminded me just of what
we've seen of this Forum Shopping to
find staffers and lawyers frankly who
agree with what Trump wants to do and
there was some element that wasn't that
way in the first term but feels like it
could be in the second I mean part of
this we recently heard Trump I mean just
over the last couple of days uh indict
his political opponent I say threaten he
was going to indict his political
opponents he said he was rooting he
wanted to root out the Vermin of the
left that's literally the term term he
used um he has extreme positions on a
range of issues of course but what do
what do you make of these kind of
increasing threats it feels a little
like the authoritarian uh WS of him are
increasing but what do you make of it
you it's it's a central theme of my book
which is and this is also something that
is different uh there is a coherent idea
now behind Trump's reelection campaign I
don't know if there was always a
coherent idea besides I'm the best I'm
the greatest I'm going to build the wall
all that stuff now it is retro rtion and
that quote that you just cited about
Vermin we're going to we're going to
we're going to get the Vermin I mean
that is Nazi imagery now I'm not saying
that Donald Trump is a Nazi but those
are the that is the IM Lang by Adolf
Hitler I'm not going to say that Donald
Trump is a Nazi I'm just going to keep
saying Nazi and Donald Trump in the same
sentence and then I'm going to say that
I'm not saying it and thank God that you
people who watch MSNBC are
complete not bright
people otherwise uh you might not see
what I'm doing but let's continue with
MSNBC because here's this guy medy
Hassan he is he is a Hamas supporter he
is a terrible terrible person and again
in some respects when you look at the
Andrea Mitchells and the medy Hans and
the Jens sakis and all of these people I
don't blame them they are puppets and
buffoons who are making six figures and
it's nice to make six figures I blame
blame the people up the chain at snbc
there is a corporate structure that
wants their lies to be heard that is the
truth and this is incredible I don't
know how John Jonathan Carl is not in
this segment because it's Hitler again
we're doing more Hitler Hitler roll
reports should terrify each and every
one of us Trump isn't hiding his
authoritarian Ambitions for a second
term from punishing his political
opponents to locking up immigrants in
camps to deploying the military all
while echoing the hateful rhetoric of
Adolf Hitler we know exactly what we can
expect if he retakes the White House in
2024 but hey what was it about Joe
Biden's age
again you know Hitler is probably
looking up right he's in hell so he's
looking up right now like these people
are complete morons like they are they
are besmirching my good name uh but
let's continue MSNBC here we go Joe Joe
scarber
I don't even have to describe these
people anymore here here Hitler go and
now we're going we're just going full on
Hitler talking about uh talking about
Vermin again he's lifting straight from
the 1930s straight from fascist then I
know there are a lot of lot of
professors that don't want to go there
they say oh maybe it's not fascism yet
but you see January 6th you see Donald
Trump praising the people that stormed
the capital tried to overthrow American
democracy and then use the same words
that Nazis in Germany used in the 30s
and musolini used in Italy wait what do
you want to call it like afternoon tea
like if it if it sounds like Nazism if
it if it walks like Nazism if he makes
threats the way he's making threats I'm
I'm not I'm not exactly sure what you
call it if you don't call it fascism is
intense to uh turn the government into
an a weapon of Revenge and retribution
uh the the plans the detailed plans for
massive
deportations and concentration camps
everything they accuse Trump of and
accuse the rest of us of is what they
are guilty of that guy at the end that
Trump Wants Revenge and retribution
against his political opponents who's on
trial right now uh for a whole bunch of
stuff there's some federal cases and
some New York cases and they're going
after his businesses and they're trying
to put him in jail and also there's a
classified document thing that also
other people like Mike Pence and Hillary
Clinton have been guilty of who who uh
it's that
Hitler anyway here's a clip from The
View I don't think they say the name
Hitler but it's implied Hitler enjoy
here don't his supporters real see that
he turns on people who are in his Corner
if you dare to go against him even this
much he goes bananas on you that's a
dictatorship they don't see the signs of
fashion and they don't see that they
will be the next victims of this vitrio
learn reality is this is he's Donald
Trump is running for president for two
reasons to stay out of jail and to get
revenge on his enemies and when he
speaks we should listen and frankly it's
scary um he's already said he's going to
come after people like General John
Kelly my former boss chairman Mark
Millie people who dare to stand against
him Mike pen journalist um I yeah I
think there's a reason for all this to
be concerned about us but there's a
there's a really interesting try it go
ahead try it we have this show every day
okay Donald um there's a really
interesting metaphor in uh Susan
glasser's book the divider about Trump
where she describes him like the
dinosaur in Jurassic Park who gets
smarter and he learns how to open the
door joy joy this brings me no joy we
used to know each other we'd bump into
each other on the upper west you'd say
hi to my
dog whatever they have pumped your face
full of they are going too close to your
brain you've got to stop them okay
they're supposed to be going under your
eyes or wherever they're supposed to be
going keep your forehead nice and clean
but they're they're going in a little
bit too far so you think that Donald
Trump wants to become president so that
he can get
you I'm pretty sure that's not high on
the priority list although maybe it
should be quite frankly um but okay this
is what they do the real Nazis and their
supporters and here's where I would say
people like Rashida and ilhan ilhan
right it's this is the crew the left
doesn't know when to stop itself right
when does the left go too far top of the
show they have the real Nazis out on the
street they are attacking Jewish
restaurants and stores they're showing
up to Temples all of the stuff that you
all know now they're not concerned about
that MSNBC is not worried about that
they are worried about the man who
already was President do didn't do any
of the things they are claiming he's
going to do this time and everything
else and and by the way guys as you know
I have my reservations about Trump if he
became president again I actually don't
think he'd be able to hire anybody good
I think it would be a cluster F Beyond
imagination and all of that stuff it
would be I would gladly take that
cluster F Beyond what's going on now but
like I'm not sitting here like w Trump
Trump trump but he's not Hitler you
idiots he was the most pro-israel
president that we had probably in five
decades maybe maybe since Truman
announced that he was recognizing the
modern state of Israel like all of the
his grandchildren are freaking Jews you
morons uh but that's what they do
they're really good at the Shell game
right they destroy everything their
people are the haters they're the ones
that are running insurrections and
occupying the capital when they want to
and it's a pro Palestine rally and
everything else and destroying stores
and black lives matter and anti they do
all the stuff but then the rest of us
who basically believe in Law and Order
and would' like to be left alone we're
all the Nazis because that's all Nazis
ever why would you just leave me
alone so now let's look at the policies
of when the left goes too far because
there's a lot of evidence of it and
unfortunately this isn't the stuff that
they cover on mainstream media let's go
over to San Francisco and you guys know
because I talk about a lot San Francisco
is a third world World hell hole so I
want to show you this video this is from
a week ago this is just a random woman
who happens to work in San Francisco and
here she is taking a video from one week
ago of the tenderloin District in San
Francisco take a
look mentally draining and
stressful situations but
dangerous to
work this is how I have to get to work
every day
those people wish they could be in Gaza
right now okay San Francisco now there's
a reason I'm showing you that San
Francisco as you know and by the way
it's not just the tender loine District
it is sprawling everywhere in that City
or I should say was sprawling everywhere
in that City uh because Gavin Newsome as
you know he went to China last week and
he's become good buddies with Chinese
president Xi Jinping and he's an
authoritarian he's a communist he keeps
people in 15-minute cities he has social
credit scores uh pretty pretty bad dude
generally you could say about x uh he he
doesn't really believe in Freedom and by
the way Gavin Nome doesn't believe in
Freedom so XI and a couple of his
buddies uh are coming over from China
and they're going to San Francisco and
you're not going to believe this they
actually cleaned up San Francisco
coincidence yes that's right the Summit
is expected to bring in $53 million
filling hotels rooms bringing big
business and the city did tidy up for
dreamforce but this cleanup is much more
extensive while San Francisco is in the
spotlight for the asia-pacific economic
conference city leaders are making sure
the city shines tourism is our business
here in San Francisco and we need to
focus on making sure that the tourist
dollars still come back calr repaving
Major roadways like the Harrison Street
offramp from the I80 Bart doubling down
by deep cleaning their stations
overnight more often the city had gotten
a little bit dingy over time scrubbing
and power washing is happening all over
the city yeah the bottom of my shoes
look clean like it's noticeable how
clear the streets look and how few
homeless encampments there are on major
thoroughfares having been a longtime
resident in the Bay Area you just
naturally start to wonder of like
houseless folks being displaced Public
Works is installing decorative
crosswalks in North Beach and Chinatown
and the Webster Street pedestrian bridge
in Japan toown was recently recently
repainted the ybab bua Gardens at the
Moscone Center are decked out with new
colorful landscaping and murals paid for
by the clean California Grant just in
time for the 20,000 high-profile CEOs
and heads of state coming into town next
week some people say this should be how
it's always done what about the people
who are here year round you know in like
local hardworking working class Bay Area
folks you guys really need to understand
how evil this is they could have done
this the entire time San fr Isco does
not have to be the way it is Los Angeles
does not have to be the way it is
Seattle Portland Etc uh as Connor
pointed out during that clip uh where
are the homeless people there are about
30 to 40,000 homeless people in San
Francisco zombie like fenel addicted
blood all over their face
drooling they barely are people that's
what these drugs do to them where are
they right now what did they do with
those people why are there no videos of
those people what did you do with them
Gavin Nome like I whatever the worst
imaginable thing that Gavin usum could
have done is to them is like that's
probably what he did does he have a
giant blender and he just put some fenel
in it like in a giant blender somewhere
and he had them just walk like Lemmings
off a thing and then he chopped them up
and then he probably uses the goo to
smear all over his face how was that for
a Morning
Show anyway here's more video of the
cleaned up San Francisco streets very
Exciter here we
are downtown San Francisco
and as you can
see they got it blocked
off I'm not a big fan of these
barricades sad our country is not safe
enough sad they got to put up
barricades can only imagine how the
ardemy art let me make a very Twisted
prediction uh you might think you might
go okay well Dave it was horrible what
was happening in San Francisco this is
their chance to turn turn around they've
cleaned it up and let's not worry about
those 30 maybe had to kill 30,000 fental
addicts we don't know where they are
let's just put them aside for just a
second um I think what Gavin Newsome is
doing is he has talked to XI jingping
and he's basically selling out San
Francisco and probably all of California
to China that China will start running
San Francisco one way or another and
there will be fences everywhere it will
be harder for people to come in and come
out nobody will have any privacy it will
be highly regulated social credit sces
like this is the beginning of it and
Gavin Newsome has brought it into
California and he wants to export that
throughout the United States that is
what we are up against at a national
level uh but if you want to hear from
Gavin Nome you may need a barf bag
because I'm about to show you two clips
um he is so profoundly evil listen to
the way he talks about how having
finally cleaned up the city folks say oh
they're just cleaning up this place cuz
all those fancy leaders are coming into
town um that's true true because it's
true but it's also true for months and
months and months prior to Apec we've
been having different
conversations it's true because it's
true before they were just talking about
it but then they decided to do it when
his when his Masters decided to come to
town he is so effing evil it is off the
charts like he is a lizard person I will
go into hiding if he becomes president
of the United States you guys can come
with me I got a bunker somewhere it's
not and I think we have Internet so
we'll keep doing the show um he he is a
bad dude you know what's interesting I I
this is my house we're in my house right
now um I keep it clean regardless of uh
whether people are coming over or not
now when people are coming over for say
a dinner party um we do clean up a
little bit more it's a little tidier uh
but we don't let the whole place become
a disheveled hav when nobody's here and
then when really fancy people are here
we just clean up the whole damn thing
like evil anyway here he is again
doubling down on what's happened here in
San Francisco anytime you put on an
event by definition you know you have
people over your house you're going to
clean up the house you 21 world leaders
you got tens of thousands of people
coming from all uh around the globe U
what an opportunity to showcase the
world's most extraordinary Place San
Francisco the world's most extraordinary
place there isn't enough Sentinel that
would get me back there um bad dude bad
dude he was the mayor of San Francisco
he's the one that destroyed San
Francisco in the first place he had a
10-year plan to get rid of homelessness
and then homelessness exploded under him
you know what he's done to Cali and then
he's just saying it like he's saying it
to your face America he's saying yeah
when we want to be able to do something
and give you clean cities and clean
streets and lower crime and all of those
things we can do it but we don't really
want to do it unless the Chinese are
coming over and then we wouldn't want to
upset them so I think we've shown you
when the left goes too far say
supporting Hamas say telling you that
Donald Trump is Hitler say destroying
cities and then only cleaning them up
when the communists come to town uh but
let's continue a little bit further
because uh Whitney Cummings who's a
comedian she was on Joe Rogan's show and
I can't verify the truth of this one I'm
going to take her word for it and we'll
check on this uh but she has also fled
California and as you know Rogan fled
California I fled California Ben Shapiro
in the daily wire fled California Elon
Musk moved most of his stuff out into
Texas although he's still in San
Francisco because of Twitter I mean
there's just been a massive Purge of
people over I think around 1.3 million
people in three years just fleeing that
state and of course they are trying to
make sure that if you flee that state
that they can still tax you because they
are evil because Gavin Newsome is an
evil communist who is under the boot of
the Chinese uh but Whitney Cummings who
is on Joe Rogan and she said this about
what's happening to the animals now of
California like a raccoon and so I call
Animal Control this is like the most
California response I'm like I have this
raccoon in my tree and she's like yeah
that's where they live I'm like yeah
know this is where I live get the
it's sick something's wrong with it last
thing I need is aing coyote eating it
and then we have rabid coyotes have to
deal with that and she goes well a lot
of the wild animals in California are
acting really weird right now because
people are testing their cocaine for
Fentanyl and if it test positive they
flush it down the toilet so they're fent
all in the water so the coyotes and
raccoons are acting really weird
what that's what she said yes I was like
if you're telling me there's fentanyl
coyotes I got to get the out of here but
how wait a minute what about people did
people get that water how is that
where's that water going I mean they
already probably where's like is that
mean that waste water from a toilet
flushing goes out into the streets like
what is this Rome I know probably this
is how they started for the same uh fade
okay I can't speak to the verac and
absolute truthiness of the claim but I
have no doubt that Media Matters will be
factchecking me on this um but the let's
just say it's ballpark sort of right
that this is what now is happening and
there will be coyotes on fenel killing
the California liberals who will be
going I think Hitler did that that's
where we're at but liberals moderates
Etc there is a way out but you're going
to have to put your money where their
where your mouth is so James Lindsay and
who I've had on the show many times
before and James has been one of like
the strongest
intellectual uh backers of Truth and
decency and anti- wokeness he saw that
clip and he wrote this I thought it was
pretty perfect he wrote yeah but it
would be like slumming it to vote for a
conservative and that still is the
position of so many liberals again Bill
Maher who I try to give a lot of credit
to let's not forget a month ago I showed
you a clip of him saying he wants Gavin
Nome to run for president while then he
rails against the woke and then sits
across someone like Bill Maher who
explains why sits across someone like
Jordan Peterson who explains why that
doesn't make any sense but until the
last liberals and I know a bunch of Jews
are waking up right now but there aren't
enough Jews to affect the the outcome of
an election but like when they're like
oh we're into your beheading your
grandma then people start do voting the
wrong way the good Libs this is up to
you guys and you know what there are
signs there are a couple signs so we're
we're almost there guys uh in Chicago oh
we're going to do a segment on Chicago
how many people were killed in Chicago
this weekend before we get to it how
many this is believe it or not my uh
segment we're about to do is not
necessarily about how many people were
killed in Chicago this weekend but it is
good to know just how many people were
shot in Chicago this weekend can I get
some numbers
please this is dead air eight dead 16
shot 16 shot eight dead low weekend man
you got something for me those are
rookie numbers yeah those are rookie get
get to it Chicago get cracking anyway um
in Chicago as you know there's crazy
crime now they've got they're a
sanctuary City so they've got all the
problem with the immigrants and
everything else the illegal immigrants I
should say the illegal aliens I should
say uh anyway uh some black people in
Chicago and black people are thought of
as oppressed in America so you have to
believe them when they say something uh
they're sort of pissed that the migrants
are getting all the services and they're
thinking about leaving the Democrats
here's check just check this out we're
here to say to Black old
who are elected by the black citizens of
Chicago that we are fed up with you not
hearing our stress and our demand but
rather do what you want to do to please
the Democratic party we are fed up with
you for not taking the lead to stop the
buses we're fed up with you for not
demanding of Brandon Johnson to remove
illegal immigrants from our communi and
we're also here to say we are we are
denouncing uh Alderman William Hall and
lont Robinson for going to the border to
look into the eyes of illegal immigrants
but has failed to look into the eyes of
homeless black men women and children
and other citizens of Chicago we have
veterans who have served this country
who are hom have you looked into their
eyes if this mass increases immigration
continues all wages and employment for
black workers and potential workers will
fall our position is that we will not
quietly sit by and allow poor destitute
people from around the world come to
Chicago and be dumped into poor
destitute communities in the city of
Chicago to please the political agenda
of black Alderman the uh the mayor of
the city of Chicago and the governor of
the state of Illinois as well as the
President of the United States reach
sister yeah everything she said there is
true they have had it they have had
Decades of democrat rule Democrats have
destroyed their City City with crime and
shootings and everything else in the
last few years Democrats have destroyed
their city with uh the sanctuary city
concept which of course just allows
illegals to come in and get services and
there aren't unlimited Services much
like there's not unlimited amounts of
anything so then you have to start
taking away from the other people who
want those Services I also have to say I
kind of dig a woman in a full denim
outfit seems like a very simple thing to
put on you know I mean I got to button
this and this and this the whole thing
just getting like a big denim thing that
seems kind of nice uh but of course
she's right and Democrats you're going
to have to choose uh who do you like
more black people or illegals and I know
that's going to be a tough one for you
because you also want the illegals to
vote which is why you don't want voter
ID but you're going to have to work that
one out uh here's just a couple images
of what's happening on the streets of
Chicago right in the area that that
woman was talking about this is right
next door by the way to the local police
department uh sent in pictures from
makeshift migrant camps near the 17th
District on Leland between Harding and
psaki these are the conditions uh these
are conditions that are neither
conducive for local residents nor
migrants indeed it's not conducive to
anything good for anybody but that is
where we are at so now I would like to
as we are one to do on this program Go
full circle I think it is fairly obvious
I think we have laid out a case that the
left has gone too far with virtually
everything so you must not support the
left anymore you must not support the
Democrat Party anymore if you want Law
and Order on your streets if you want a
border if you want to make sure that
Jackal can't ransack businesses and by
the way eventually because of that
oppressed depressor narrative start
blowing up buses right here and start
murdering people right here uh you
better stop voting for these people
right uh so now I got two more for you
real quick uh this is Fox reporting that
uh some of the migrants who are coming
into Chicago they they can't take it in
Chicago they can't cannot deal with
shooting and the murder in the Mayhem
and they're going back from where they
came 623 here in New York City some
migrant families think Chicago is so
unpleasant they would rather return to
their home countries than face a brutal
winter in the Windy City without jobs or
even places to live one Venezuelan
migrant told the Chicago Tribune quote
the American dream doesn't exist anymore
at least for
them at least for them I mean the
Chicago winds can be quite brutal it is
the windy city uh but do you see what
they've done they have destroyed our
cities every time someone steps up and
say we'd like Law and Order we'd like
not to allow this they call you Hitler
and everything else and what they have
also done through education is they have
created an absolute generation of Young
Americans who hate America they hate
Freedom they think we are evil and as I
keep saying if you think they can
disconnect the Jewish people from the
ancient land of Israel that that old
testament's about and Jesus who was born
in Judea the story of Hanukkah which
took place in the Judean Hills and all
of that stuff uh did you ever see the
Ten Commandments the movie with Charlton
hon yeah that's about the Hebrews
leaving Egypt going to Israel uh but if
they can disconnect those things what do
you think they can do to you in
America I think you know and my friend
Megan Kelly on her podcast yesterday
went off I believe uh what would the
kids call this fire would they say this
is fire here's based fire from Megan
Kelly you don't like America get out get
out we don't want you here either you
don't want to be here we don't want you
it's perfect go
home honestly like these half these
people are chanting an Arabic about this
country that they've clearly chosen but
it's not good enough for them get
out we don't need you again you can come
to my place for tequila anytime right
like this is a time for
choosing and for the Democrats who are
waking up you must choose do you want to
go down with that ship and destroy this
country and be beheaded a little bit
later like Andrea Mitchell or do you
want to go like this pinch your nose and
go oh my God maybe I'll have to find
common cause with those conservatives
because they do believe in Law and Order
they do think that the founding of
America is kind of okay and they do know
that when you put babies in ovens that's
bad and everything else that is the
choice and I suspect many of them will
disappoint us but maybe not all of them
but to Megan's Point stop being nice
guys it's not helping us anymore stop
being lofty and having your ideals and
watching people trample over your rights
and eventually show up to your home and
everything else it will kill you you and
it will kill your country quite
literally we've got a postgame show
coming up in about 20 seconds Ruben
report. locals.com people of the
internet will be live at 2m today and
I'll be on Russell Brand's podcast in
about 20 minutes I think my full
interview with ion her Al is up across
platforms and it's a bit of a non seor
for our cold close today but we leave
you with just sort of classic old Joe
Biden goodbye that's why I and so damn
many other people I grew up have cancer
and why can't for the longest time
Delaware had the highest cancer rate in
the nation America is a nation that can
be defined in a single word I was the
foot him foot excuse
me Mr
Haney we're doing it for the first time
now in the 20 21st century going into
the 20 from the 20th century going into
the second quarter of the 21st century
that we'd say 12 years is enough I think
12 years enough in going into 20 30 40
50 the rebuilding of uh of of Syria of
uh of Libya of you know this is they're
there and I want to thank the prime
minister of for Colombia's leadership in
the a assion
chair
[Music]